hey guys and welcome back to the Leia
heilpan show joining me on the show
today we have a certified personal
trainer and nutritionist of over 20
years so I've got a lot of questions for
him he also has an eight-figure business
so again more questions coming I'm
really excited to learn about this he's
also a best-selling author on Amazon and
he's done a lot of different modeling as
well for the likes of Nike Puma and
Adidas so it sounds like he's done it
all so let's welcome to the show Brandon
Carter also known as king keto Brandon
welcome what's going on thank you for
having me man it's a pleasure to be here
yeah I'm so excited to speak with you um
you've done a lot of different things
and I feel like you're really sort of
leading in the online entrepreneurial
space and the fitness space so I'm
excited to break all of that down but
before we get into it I was really
curious about the king keto name yeah so
where did that come from does that mean
you know you're the you're the king of
the ketogenic diet is that what you do
like where did the name come from yo I
had like a stupid name that kind of
escapes me on Instagram him and uh one
of my one of my boys he was like man you
should change the name to King keto on
Instagram and then I just changed it
um so I had to buy it from some guy who
wasn't even using it and uh
and that's that's kind of how it that
was the Genesis of it because uh he you
know I've been a strong proponent at a
ketogenic diet you know for for many
years and and so it just kind of it just
kind of fit yeah I feel like diets right
now are really trending you know
everybody's trying a different diet and
me and my brother we're also trying to
do different diets I think he's doing
better with the whole keto and Carnival
diet than I am um so we're gonna I'm
gonna ask you all about that but I'm
curious before we get into it can you
explain the different benefits of
something like a keto versus carnivore
versus like even being vegan because I
see that being pushed a lot
um you know what are the differences as
it pertains to diet it really depends on
what your aspirations are you know like
what your goals are if you just want to
lose fat then anything will work right
you don't have to be keto you can eat
all the carbs in the world it doesn't
really matter you just have to burn more
calories than you consume so a common
misconception
about the ketogenic diet is that people
only do it for body composition reasons
right but that's not why I do it at all
you know
um I do from a number of different
reasons I get like way different health
benefits that are associated with it for
example
when I was uh you know I was in my 30s
like early mid mid
I was in my early 30s you look like
you're in your 30s oh thank you no I'm
40. I'll be 41. I'll be 41 this month I
mean September and um
it was like early 30s and it said my
cholesterols I I went for a checkup and
I have a genetic predisposition for that
because I have a lot of family members
with high cholesterol and they wanted to
put me on like Statin medications and I
was like and after being like a trainer
for so long and training nutrition for
so long I I was familiar with some
studies that showed that the ketogenic
diet
had had the ability to lower cholesterol
in some people not everyone right so I
said you know what man instead of doing
these crazy ass drugs right because it's
a lot of side effects associated with
those
I said let me just try this instead but
what I noticed is that I just feel
better I feel like I have more energy my
skin was super clear after that and I
know I just felt better right so I I I I
stick I stuck with it then I went back
to the doctor and he was like oh did you
you those little drugs been working I
was like man I I ain't I ain't I threw
that prescription away oh wow yeah
because my cholesterol had had dropped
back down to a a acceptable rate what
did the doctor say he was like oh we'll
just keep doing what you're doing and I
was like yeah no I'm gonna keep doing it
and that's what that's the main reason I
started but then the more I researched
it you know the studies to show it
boosts immune system for example I
haven't had a cold in like six years wow
yeah when everyone had like you know the
flu yeah
you know or whatever you know I'm
walking around New York like I Am Legend
you know what I'm saying because I was
living in Manhattan at the time and yeah
my girl got it three times and I was
kissing her in the mouth eating off her
plate having unprotected sex with her I
ain't even test positive
I haven't been sick why didn't you put
her on the diet oh man cause she's
Dominican yeah
Latino you know they eat they you know
they eat a lot of rice man my folks love
rice
yeah yeah okay okay that's fascinating
but well that's so interesting because
the whole
um the whole thing with keto and you
know eating let's say like red meat and
fat and all of that they say that that
is bad for cholesterol but they say
that's the direct issue they say a lot
of things they do what's your take on
that well here's the thing this this is
an axiom of life right everything's
hypothetical until you apply to your own
life right if you read any study they
never say a hundred percent of people
got this result you know so you may be
an outlier right or someone else may be
outlier everything is hypothetical until
you apply it to your own life so when
people say this is the best this is the
best it's the best like
you'll never hear me say keto's the best
you'll never hear me say anything's the
best because it might not be the best
for you you know what I'm saying like
yeah you know some people have great
results with a vegan diet some people
[__] their whole [__] up you know some
people have great results with um
uh carnivore diet but some people they
they can't handle it right everybody's
different man so people eat somebody
will somebody listening this right now
who would die if they ate a peanut you
know what I'm saying like everything's
hypothetical until you apply to your own
life right so I don't really even get
caught up in a lot of the
as it pertains to me I don't get caught
up in a lot of the studies I
but that may influence me to attempt
something right and see if it's
applicable to me in my life that makes
sense yeah no that doesn't make sense so
how can somebody figure out which diet
would be better for them and the reason
I ask is because there's so much
controversy over diets and I hear some
um I have some rules for men and I feel
like there's some for women so like uh
intermittent fasting apparently is good
for men but not for women
um I've heard that uh keto is better for
men not for women so how do you know
like is there a certain type of person
that should gravitate towards a specific
type of diet everything is hypothetical
no until you apply it to your own life
okay like literally everything you know
so I'm real super hesitant to say that
this is good for men or this is good for
women because how are you going to say
how are you going to generalize half the
population that's [__] billions of
people you know uh I will say
you could look at the studies I'm sorry
I would say you can look at the studies
and you know the evidence
to
to maybe assess what might be beneficial
for you you know what I'm saying uh but
also the question is like the best diet
it's also what are your goals like what
are you trying to accomplish right you
know like when we were trying to
accomplish something similar like it
depends looking good lean body I guess
maybe put on some like muscle mass but
like get rid of fat isn't everyone maybe
do the same thing maybe right not I mean
maybe because think about it some people
want to be pro athletes some people want
are thinking about longevity you know
some people are just want to get as big
as possible some people want to be
um more flexible some people want to to
gain weight so people want to lose
weight some people want to be like a
bodybuilder some people just want to be
thin you know it's like everyone has
different goals and different
aspirations so
to say that one thing is the best
it really just depends on what what
their goals are and then we got to see
you know what was going to work best for
that person and what they can adhere to
you know what I'm saying like the best
diet is the one that helps you
accomplish your goals and you can adhere
to it like some people just can't do
keto because it's just not going to work
for them you know um and that's cool
yeah that makes sense I mean I've
personally tried the
um the the keto diet and I don't know
maybe I'm just not doing it properly but
I find it really difficult like
something I need something like I need I
need some type of carb like rice
whatever I think I don't know because I
get low energy and then like I really I
get hungry I get so hungry yeah maybe
like it may be that maybe that's the
case um
I will say though most people who say
they try keto like they don't really do
it properly yeah like almost no one
right I had this I had this one uh
employee
and he was working for me this is when I
was back in New York and he he wanted to
start the ketogenic diet right because
he you know he saw the benefits I was
getting and he wanted to try it and he
was like man
I got no energy but I'm not hungry
what's going on and what when you
actually are in ketosis right what
happens is your body starts to
um produce ketones and what
one of the side effects is that is that
it makes you less hungry right so a lot
of times this will happen to him a lot
of times people won't eat enough so it's
like how much you've been eating he said
I don't know you're not tracking it and
I got [__] pissed at him for not
tracking it and then uh so we
went through what did you eat yesterday
man what you eat and we we added it up
in my fitness pal and he had like a
thousand calories yesterday like of
course nothing of course you're [__]
yeah you don't have energy right you got
to eat more but he wasn't hungry because
of Keto so I will say the people who do
it right sometimes they find it
beneficial that they're not hungry like
that's a benefit if you're doing it
properly like you shouldn't be hungry at
all it's that in fact sometimes I have
to
I had to make sure I'm hitting the right
amount I'm getting enough calories you
know because your hunger kind of escapes
you how many calories you having
for right like if I'm doing a cut I'm
trying to get leaner then
I'll probably be somewhere around
2000 2500 calories
but it also depends on how active I am
right you know there's something
as far as
burning fat right it doesn't matter what
cap what diet you're on it's all about
if you burn more calories you consume
but these [__] Fitness [__] they
don't tell people to wear a fitness
tracker like like the [__] are
guessing how much calories they burn and
they wonder why they're not whether or
not
um get in the shape so
I recommend you get like the Apple you
can get Apple watch but you know I got
different watches
or I'm sorry or Aura ring
or ring or [__] Fitbit won't ban
anything to to try to get a fair
assessment how many calories you're
actually burning and then you see how
many you consume and then it's just
simple math yeah life is just math the
stock market's volatility lately has
been a good reminder of why we diversify
our portfolios new data from UBS shows
private assets like Fine Art can be
especially valuable when looking for low
correlation as they have historically
moved independent of stocks now
according to Bloomberg last year art
prices increased along with the highest
total sales ever for major auction
houses and the Art Market has actually
passed pre-pandemic levels but how can
you take advantage of this well tens of
thousands of everyday investors already
use today's sponsor Masterworks where
you can invest without needing millions
of dollars or even an art degree every
painting Masterworks has sold to date
has delivered a positive return to their
investors including annualized net
returns of 10 17 and even 35 this year
among others also Masterworks actually
just completed their 16th exit a
consumer piece just a few weeks ago now
shares of each offering are limited but
you guys get special access to skip the
wait list all you have to do is go to
masterworks.art forward slash layer so
I'm curious are there any
um like superhuman foods and are there
any bad foods superhumans yeah they say
like they say like like blueberries and
honey and raw milk what are you talking
about I don't know this is what I'm
hearing I guess that's why you're here I
know nothing no no no I'm not saying
that like blueberries definitely have a
lot of benefits you know for example
they're full of antioxidants which which
can help in certain aspects of different
Health parameters and you know but it's
like again it depends on what your goals
are right you know
it depends on what you goes for your
goals are and what you're trying to
accomplish and what your body needs you
get what I'm saying like yeah it's uh
it's super hard for me to make broad
prescriptions okay for the general
population you know okay so is there
anything that's that's bad okay so the
reason I ask is because I hear that um
that oats because everybody loves oats
but I hear those bad because it's like
actually anti-nutrients
um so it like absorbs the nutrients of
other things that you have so apparently
oats is bad apparently greens like
spinach is bad and broccoli is bad and
asparagus is bad please give me your
take I've been arguing with my brother
about this and it would argue with loads
of people about this I know the carnego
the carnivore guys they they say that a
lot you know and
if that's their experience and that's
you know I'm not here to dispute that
you know
diplomatic is honest right you can get
on
you know the easiest way to be the
easiest way to blow up on social media
is to go on different podcasts and talk
crazy or talk crazy on your own but on
your own podcast because that's the
easiest way to blow up and get attention
right you'll Galvanize the people who
agree with you and you'll piss off the
people who don't and it's easier to piss
people off than it is to make them happy
correct I think about it's easier to
piss people off and make it happy right
so it's like low-hanging fruit it's
[__]
you know they don't they don't
they might not have [__] that's
compelling on their own right so it's
easy to be divisive right being divisive
is is a Surefire way to get notoriety
you know and
I just don't need to do that [__] you
know I already got it popping so I don't
need to go I don't need to be out here
pissing people off just to make it mad
because the truth is I've trained like
some of these [__] on the internet
you know some of them not everybody's
smart people but some of these
[__] they just like fit these
guys Fitness girls but they never been
trainers or they never been trainers
like I've been a trainer since I was 16
you know what I'm saying I'll be 41 to
see it right like when how are you
mid-20s yeah
but I just had my butt oh well happy
birthday man mid-20s right so I think
about that that means like possibly
before you was born I was training 10
people a day you know in the gym right
so
this is like thousands of people
thousands and thou literally thousand
people especially then when I went
online I'm training so many people doing
their diet plans and stuff and now I
train trainers like I train trainers sir
so once you get that breadth of
knowledge it's it's it's it's not me
being diplomatic it can come off that
way to [__] dummies
yo dumbass uh because they don't know
[__] right and they used to listen to
guys who are like real Boombastic and
have like you know unnecessary bravado
right but
for me I just know the truth that like
everybody's different you know and you
want to and and if you're a really good
trainer if you're a really good trainer
you can train anybody with any
methodology you know what I'm saying
like if you're really good right the
[__] who thinks he's good can
only help people uh help a certain kind
of person do a certain kind of thing
right you give me anybody
you give me anybody I help him
accomplish his or her goal and
with every protocol you want you should
come to me say man I want to do vegan
keto
yeah you can do it that's the thing you
can do it because the ketogenic diet is
just a macronutrient ratio right so you
can get those same Master it's super
difficult but you can get those
macronutrients in a vegan diet right if
you wanted to so that's the most complex
thing I can think of all right cool
let's do it I'll come up with the plan
right you know put me in any situation
give you a cool off today you seem like
you know everything like I don't know
it's good it's good you know and and
that's why
so like I I appreciate you saying I was
just uh diplomatic but I wasn't trying
to be diplomatic it's just when you
really
Socrates said you know I I don't I only
thing I know is that I don't know or
some [__] like that man it's a long time
ago right but you know is the
[__] who's sure about [__]
he's he's probably the least
knowledgeable you know yeah it's like
it's like when um they say somebody who
can who can honestly say like I don't
know but let me find out and get back to
you yeah is like the most trustworthy
and probably the more honorable
individual than somebody who's like oh
yeah like uh yeah I don't know
everything yeah I got it it's like you
know yeah it's called the Dundon Krueger
effect right where people believe they
learn a little bit right
right and it's so it's what they didn't
know right but now they learned a little
bit and they think they know everything
right and you see that all over the
Internet you know like yeah you'll see a
guy he got in great shape for himself
right or a girl she got an amazing shape
for herself
but that doesn't mean you can
extrapolate that [__] to the general
population you know what I'm saying it's
like you guys like that response because
like you know I've I'm always trying
different things especially being in the
states
um I don't know how well you are but the
food in the states is completely
different to how it is in England so
when I first moved here English food is
uh gross no
but it worked out you know what I'm
saying it really worked out for y'all
the Indian food is good not the regular
food you might you might enjoy it no so
look England's a large country it's
obviously not as big as the states we
have a variety of foods but the main
difference is the way that the food is
did you say England was a large country
it is like smaller than Texas
I said not as big as the states it's not
a large country the United Kingdom is
you know a little bit bigger and then we
have Europe in general like a wide
variety in Europe
um thank you
um but the way it's processed is
completely different so like when I
first came to the states I was eating
how I would eat in England and um like
my whole body blew up like I didn't get
I wouldn't say I was fat Gideon's like
don't tell people if I actually weren't
fat but my body just like blew up and
that's because of all like the hormones
that they put in the food yes yeah well
you think I was like eating too much
well no you know you were you ever heard
of the the twinkie diet no all right so
you can Google this when you get a
chance right there was a there was a
professor at some [__] school the
Name Escapes me but he wanted to prove
that really weight loss and weight gain
was just calories and calories out so he
went on uh just like Diet primarily
consisting of Twinkies right like the
[__] barely it's barely food right
you know and um and he lost he lost a
ton of weight just like managing his
calories you know yeah I know that's
crazy that's obviously like true I don't
think you were eating that bad no it's
not bad but I just I just noticed like
when I go out for dinner in America my
body just blows up compared to when I
got for dinner in England now you think
I'm crazy but
this leads you on to a question which I
feel like you're just gonna disregard
now no no look I wanted to ask you about
like the getting good meat in in America
because like I find that there's a
difference between getting um like a
steak for example from like Publix and
Whole Foods versus going to a farmer's
market so is there a difference like
what do you think where's the best place
to get meat there probably is man but
when you look at the statistics of like
what do people are really dying from in
America right it's obesity related
diseases right according to the World
Health Organization you know um 1400
Americans Americans die every day from
obesity related diseases they're not
dying from [__] pesticides or meat
wasn't organic like the biggest threat
to human life in America is obesity
related diseases it's like excess
calories you know what I'm saying and
and so when people want to make
everything organic and I'm not against
that right you know I mean I can
probably have flaws and that right a lot
of
a lot of stuff that's labeled organic is
they still pray with pesticides it's
just like or it's just Organic
pesticides they still have to use
pesticides otherwise [__] this shit's
gonna be [__] up the crops are gonna
get [__] up but some of those some of
those natural pesticides are are just as
carcinogenic as the synthetic ones but
whatever you know if you want to eat all
organic [__] that's cool right but I I
just think when people make a big deal
out of that they're majoring in the
miners right you know they're making a
big deal out of minors right and I see a
lot of like
when people say that you know they're in
a good position they're like super
privileged right like where I'm from
South Side Chicago like I'm from the
hood right I mean oh I can only eat
organic meat man I hope I get food you
know and it's like oh how am I going to
eat today you know what I'm saying so
like that's the domain of the privileged
right all organic meat you know and all
that other [__] uh the truth is man A
lot a lot of guys in my experience a lot
of people who I've seen who like make a
big deal about that right and and I'm
not saying you're you're in fantastic
shape your brother's in great shape you
know saying looking looks like he works
out he's in good shape and um it's it's
I don't mean like YouTube right but a
lot of times people will like use that
as a scapegoat because it's easier for
like a somebody with like some
disposable income to just throw money at
a problem than it is to really like look
at the [__] real truth is that yo you
just eating too much fat boy
you know it's like so once you get so
once you once you get your calorie
consumption under control then you can
focus on the minor [__] yeah I'm sorry I
hope I didn't answer no no that's good
that's one people to focus on the major
[__] you know what's the major stuff
take me through it what's the major
stuff consuming more calories than you
burn getting fat like getting fat is Yo
1400 Americans die every day so being in
a calorie deficit is like the most
important if you want to lose fat it's
not the most important thing it's the
only thing right you know everything
else is just a another road to that path
right you know it's like if me and you
wanted to go to the Heat game right now
we wanted to go to the key the whatever
they're calling it now you know whatever
man you know it's like we can take a
bunch of different routes there but as
long as we get there right it doesn't
[__] matter right you want to do keto
you want to be vegan you want to eat
regular [__] you want to do if if it's
your Macros it doesn't [__] matter as
long as we get there right so excuse me
like yeah I called myself King keto
right you know but I don't I just call
that self because I'm an arrogant
[__] right you know the truth the
truth is I'm not trying to push keto on
anyone do whatever you want me I don't
care what you eat as long as you eat the
right proportions to help you accomplish
your goal that's like the major [__] man
that's the major [__] so 1400 Americans
dying every day to put that in
perspective only 3 000 people died in 9
11. wow yeah so it's like just under 911
deaf numbers every other day yeah but
it's like we don't make a big deal about
it because it's so gradual and it's so
normalized right well you know what we
do we celebrate it we put fat women on
the front of uh Cosmo and we say this is
healthy yeah you go you're going now and
that's you know what but I
you know what what it is man that's like
that's a that's a negative consequence
of the free market I'm a free market
Economist right I'm saying like I'm all
about the free market right but that's a
consequence of the free market right if
if the average American is 17 pounds
overweight the average is 17 pounds
overweight right so it's like if you're
Cosmopolitan you're trying to sell these
[__] magazines you need to hey
you gotta appeal to your demographic you
know what I'm saying so people want to
blame the media or they want to play
like I'll be in uh Victoria's Secret
buying [__] for my girl and I see like
fat mannequins you know what I'm saying
that's like new [__] right and but it's
like
you know I one of my boys got mad they
trying to push this [__] on like they're
not trying to push anything
[__] are just fat and like the
market the market they got it they got
to appeal to that demographic somehow
right because that that's how that's a
consequence of free market of the free
market economy
um out of interest do you not think it's
like a little bit more sinister or you
just think it's like free market like we
got a fat audience might as well cater
to these fat people yeah yeah same [__]
you know like when I when I used to be a
model right there was there wasn't a lot
of jobs for black models right you know
especially in the early 2000s and but
that's not racist right we only
represent 10 of the population right so
if you want to make the most money they
need to go to the biggest Democrat it's
not racist it's just that's that's how
the free market works man you know yeah
well I was I was saying I was thinking
more like you know because like fat
people they have they'll develop all
these health problems and they're gonna
be the biggest con uh the biggest uh
customer of big Pharma and you know they
can make more money I just wondered if
you thought it was cheaper that's all
well more conspiratorial because that's
just yeah that's where your brain goes
all the Bitcoin people they love
conspiracies you know
um
listen I'm not gonna say it's not yeah
maybe but
it could be that oh these people are
getting fat let's let's monetize it
exactly all right for me that makes more
sense instead of like conspiracy to
fatten up America and then they make
money of them me is like oh they getting
fat we'll make money off this but if you
wanted to but honestly if they like
people people was one thing I one thing
I know
about humans is they will sell you
anything right so if if everybody
decided they wanted to get healthy they
wanted to get then they do that [__]
right you know like
I think about all the
yo man share it with us like processing
a million things yeah you know think
about like this this shirt it looked
like some regular [__] it's Lululemon
it's expensive you know like as far as
like it's not yeah yeah but like that's
for that's athleisure right that's all
they made a whole new category to
monetize Fitness right
the the organic [__] like
it's so expensive right and they and it
doesn't even have to be right those
those oh my God so I feel some tricks
right now that's what a conspiracy is
right like organic [__] doesn't
necessarily have to be more
it's a produce because the the
the the pet they still use pesticides
right so the Organic pesticides are not
like way more expensive than synthetic
ones right but they're going to charge
you that premium because they know that
that demographic is going to be people
with disposable income in it and they
want to relieve relieve them of that you
know what I'm saying no they'll monetize
anything right it's just you know I've
trained enough people to know that
people are just fat and lazy you know
what I'm saying people are people are
just [__] lazy with that
yo man these people suck man
like the average the average American is
a [__] dumbass loser right they
got less than a thousand dollar like
statistically at less than a thousand
dollars in the bank account you know and
that's why like immigrants especially
where I'm from like you know in the hood
like you'll see some immigrants that
come through man build building oh man
oh some Chinese people that come in
they're like oh [__] we gonna build a um
a dry cleaner right we're going with a
laundromat they come in and take
advantage of it where people where I was
from just like [__] sit they've been
there whole time at the same advantages
right you know and didn't capitalize on
it because Americans yo we a lot of us
are [__] lazy spoiled entitled people
you know so they're going to sit around
just being lazy if they if you would
have put that one of these mostly most
of you [__] in one of these
[__] countries you'd be [__] up you'd
be real [__] up you know what I'm
saying yeah that's an immigrant
mentality yeah immigrants immigrants go
so [__] hard man like
they just they they because they
appreciate it right like we don't it
it's not necessarily our fault right
scientists psychologists call it
hedonistic adaptation right so whatever
when there's like luxuries or you know
benefits that you that you experience on
a consistent basis you get used to them
they come normal they normalize right so
you don't appreciate them as much you
know and you know we're just a victim of
that uh but you can still rise above it
but immigrants come over they come from
a [__] show right and that's why they
want to come here right because it's
just the [__] greatest country in the
world man you know y'all y'all look your
home is a close
fifth or six you know
yeah but
they want to come here now now [__] with
England really hard London's like my
second favorite city in the world it's
okay I don't like it I don't really like
it
man you know they really like the the
women really like black Americans over
there you know what I'm saying yeah in
my experience
I was exotic when I went over there you
know what I'm saying
America has like more mixed more mixed
looking people yeah as we have in
England I think I don't know listen I
don't know the demographics I just know
what I just know as soon as I hit the
hit Heathrow man this [__] it's like
I feel like I feel like Michael Jackson
in the 80s
it's like I'm [__] Chris Brown when I
went as soon as I hit Heathrow
I'm not 100 sure you know okay I I I you
know I'm for all intensive purposes I'm
black because that's how I grew up and
that's how I was raised but uh my mom
was black and white my dad was an orphan
like he didn't know none of his uh
family right are you like do you have
any like Latin are you having any like
Hispanic in you you think so man my dad
my dad spoke Spanish and he had brown
curly hair my hair is brown and curly
back in the day yeah and uh and he spoke
Spanish and like for no reason but he
you know we we wasn't yeah we're not
really sure I think it's like it's like
the little bit of like Hispanic
potentially in you which gives you that
like exotic yeah look to the English
people to look at I think yeah because
you know we don't really have people
like that me no say there we go okay
well there you go it adds to the mystery
yeah I didn't even I never even looked
into it you know like yeah people you
don't want to do 23 and me I don't give
a [__] yeah right it's like you know for
what you know what I'm gonna say you
know like it's
um I'm the future man one day
everybody's gonna look like me yeah
except they're gonna be fatter
yeah no I'm I'm excited for that like
you know a lot of times people get mad
almost all my friends are like super
right wing
Republicans and [__] and that's kind of
funny to me
um why is that funny it's funny because
I I didn't grow like that you know like
I didn't grow up I'm apolitical I don't
give a [__] right
um no matter who's in office I'm gonna
find a way to win you know that's the
mindset yeah I'll give up yeah you have
a great mindset I'm curious thank you
where did that come from because you
know you said you came from uh and I
quote the hood yeah you said you came
from Chicago and um
I don't know what that means but
apparently that means that's the worst
side that means something yeah yeah it's
like it's like the south side of London
it's not great yeah it's reputations is
you know it's it's real yeah it speaks
for itself yeah so you know you
obviously come from the south side of
Chicago
um you've built this eight figure
business
um you know you you don't care who's
who's the president which is amazing
because that's like not victim mentality
everybody blames their problems on oh
you know I can't get a job because
Trump's president or or like I can't get
a job because Biden's taxing all of us
you know everybody blames everybody
outsources their problems and yeah
you're here and you're just like I don't
care what color I am I don't care what
my background is fact is I'm gonna do
well I'm doing well that's all that
matters so how did you get that
mentality where did that come from you
know what man
it's probably from a lot of hardships if
I'm being honest you know there's a lot
of hardships and I had to find a way to
find a ways to win you know my father
committed suicide when I was like in my
early 20s and uh and I had to like take
care of the whole family I had to figure
[__] out and it wasn't really even time
to mourn or to be sad about it you know
so I
and it was during uh 2008 right during
the recession the Great Recession so we
had like record unemployment in in New
York I mean in the United States [__]
the world right you know and you might
be too young to really like understand
what what OA was like but it was like a
real scary time like financially you
know for the world economy and there was
people with master's degrees who was
working at Starbucks like for real you
know like that it was it was it was some
like it was some other [__] and but I
was like you know what I this this is
where I'm at you know I really have time
to mourn so I just started working I was
a trainer right I would train wake up at
four train people in the morning shower
at the gym then go work security then I
did that five days a week right and then
on the weekends I would train people in
the morning and then I manage the
restaurant in Queens New York uh I was a
weekend manager at that restaurant you
know so I was working like seven seven
days a week 12 14 hours a day uh for
like two years right you know right
after my father killed herself because I
you know I had to dig dig my mom and my
you know I'm saying sister and Grandma
out of that hole out of the hole we were
in and I just noticed that oh [__] man
if I could work my way out of that
problem I can like work my way out of
any problem man so it's like
I don't give a [__] who wins the
election I mean I may have preferences
when the yeah I may have preferences but
it's not I don't have a strong bias
either way I'm like all right this
happens then I'll do this if this
happens I'll do that right you know like
when um
[__] uh
I ain't like a lot of [__] that was
happening in New York I lived in
Manhattan for like 15 years and I was
like I just moved right I wasn't even
[__] tripping about it you know I
wasn't like crying like all my [__]
friends it was weird man sometimes my I
feel like sometimes my um my right wing
friends are [__] crying more than my
left wings I have a real collected green
uh friend group and it's like they don't
even realize they're crying like they're
always complaining about [__] I'm like
man just get money man what'd you figure
it out we're gonna get money no matter
what we can't just we can't control the
election I have one friend close friend
this dude was like one of he's one of
the best ad buyers in the world or he
was right he did he like there's a lot
of like
you know nine figure companies that he
was running their ads for right and then
uh when when Trump lost the election he
like was one of the guys who's storing
the capital like he's in prison now you
know it was like [__] is you doing man
like what was you trying what did you
think he was going to accomplish dummy
you know what I'm saying like like what
the [__] did you think he was gonna
accomplish you know it's so weird that
people like let the outside
circumstances influence them that way
I'm just like yo whatever whatever
happens I'ma find a way to win I'm gonna
find a way to be victorious no matter
what I don't give a [__] you know yeah
that's powerful yeah yeah that's that's
incredible and
how did you move then your your uh
offline you know in real world business
to the online yeah and when did you do
that and how did you know like okay
there's a market for this this is like a
super smart thing that I could do you
know
so when it comes to online training it's
like I was one of the Pioneers in that
field I don't want to say I invented it
but I was definitely in the class of
people who were pioneering that and
because this was like early 2009 2010
you know and I
I just I was I was reading a lot of
books you know on the train in New York
and you know going back and forth and uh
I read uh the four hour work week by Tim
Ferriss and that was a book that was
like oh wait a minute what if I started
training people online it sound it was a
novel idea at the time right it was it
was a novel idea and it wasn't like a
precedence for it right well yes did you
say like 2009 2010. oh wow yeah yeah
yeah yeah Instagram didn't exist no
that's a crazy idea yeah so it was wild
I think we had to figure it out yeah and
then one thing I did was I
I said okay maybe if I can just like
track what these people are eating each
day right
I can help them lose weight and I can
give him the workout right now they may
not have perfect form they might not do
it great right but I know that diet is
the most important thing like you can't
train a bad diet but you can out diet
bad training
you can't diet
yeah yeah but you can't you can't yes
nah that's all good take your time
you know um and we got I I thought that
okay all I gotta do is
track their their calories and their
macros each day right and get them the
tracking and send it to me so we were
doing that and we figured that out and
what I noticed was
those online clients were getting better
results than in-person clients because I
wasn't doing that with the in-person
class almost no in-person trainer tracks
every you know all their clients macros
like almost none of them right and I was
like holy [__] these [__] are
losing more weight right
and I and then I was like okay I need to
find out how to replicate this and so I
was getting more clients and I would
notice that I can charge them less and I
can work less right because I don't have
to be in the gym with them for an hour
they're not paying me for a time like
like a like a [__] prostitute and I
paid me for the hour they're paying me
for the results they pay me for the
training plan and the accountability
right and they were getting great
results so it's like [__] this man we
need to take that you know that's what
that's the kind of how it started you
know and now
and I was able to build that keep going
and I built that up to like
you know multi-seven figures and then
you know I had a supplement line at one
point and I started man then I started
you know at the same time I'm building
YouTube and I got my YouTube pretty big
you know a few hundred thousand
followers at the time and I started
managing uh other other uh influences
like
people had big following we would help
them monetize it so I started running
their businesses running the ads for
them running the um
they didn't know how to do it either
right we're running the ads for them
running uh running the programs I had
staff you know basically doing anything
everything all they had to do was make
the videos you know what I'm saying and
those that was those are lucrative deals
you know they made more money than they
had ever made and you know we were able
to make a bunch and then
uh now I teach other people how to start
their own online businesses so my
business a high ticket trainer that's
what that's my main business that I run
now yeah it's super dope yeah no it's
incredible and there are clearly like so
many different ways to make money online
and some people still don't get it their
brains still don't click when you tell
them you can make money from anywhere in
the world
um so um I'm curious can we give like a
little bit more
um
just I guess I want to give more value
to the audience about different ways
that people can make money online so you
talk about like being a fitness trainer
and then teaching people how to do what
you did building their businesses what
other way because I know a lot of like I
do crypto I also do Forex which I'm
gonna talk more about later but but like
what other ways can people make money
online well you know like business is
super simple
it's like people make [__] more complex
than they need to you know and it's
really
businesses providing a product of
service to people for more money than it
costs you to deliver it right that's all
it is right so this you got to just have
some sort of product or service that
people find valuable and then you gotta
learn Marketing sales in a way so you're
able to um
can you know convince them to buy you
know so it's appealing to them you know
so
what about like hiring marketing people
or would you say as an entrepreneur you
should be able to do everything you know
so here's the thing about business why
starting it so hard like you got to do
everything first right you gotta so you
got to learn all these different skill
sets you got to learn whatever product
whatever product or service you're
delivering you gotta make sure that's
good right so the product development
right and then you got to learn
marketing and if you're doing sales you
got to learn sales then you got to
handle the customer service then if you
start
you know that's why then when you start
making some money you start hiring
people but now you got to learn uh how
to hire people how to manage teams and
you got to learn leadership it's super
difficult yeah you know what I'm saying
it's super difficult and that's why you
know majority of businesses fail like
only five percent of businesses get to
the million dollar mark because it's
just super difficult there's so much to
learn you know and uh I don't know if
I'm answering your questions yeah yeah I
mean do you think anyone can be an
entrepreneur and do what you did and you
know lift themselves out of poverty
um anyone can lift themselves out of
poverty for sure you know like you just
[__] is lazy I don't know about
the whole entrepreneurship but like
because you know it takes a certain
thing about it 80 of businesses fail
right yeah would you would you get in a
car that had that 80 of them [__]
crashed like you know what I'm saying
would you would you would you um if you
had an 80 chance of [__] getting sick
from a meal would you eat it you know
like it's you got to be
super
almost like crazy to do it you know and
yeah Rick's tolerance has to be super
high you got to be really um
persistent
you know and and because you really
persistent because a lot of times people
say man I tried this and it didn't work
I was like you're just not good at it
yet yeah that doesn't mean it doesn't
work it's just you couldn't get to work
somebody could have right so it's like
it's
most people don't have that you know so
I I don't know if anybody can be
entrepreneur even like when people want
to join my program to be a personal
trainer like we'd be like hey man it's
gonna be a lot of hard work you sure man
yeah like for real yeah you sure man you
sure you don't want to [__] just have
your work in the job
get that paycheck man yes and like like
didn't live then spend the rest of your
time with your [__] friends and
family man like because because
especially if you want to make a million
dollars that's just gonna take
everything yeah like it's really gonna
take everything like he's gonna take
everything you're gonna lose a lot that
that amount of sacrifice is not
everybody's cut out for it and
I know it's it's real like popular in
these entrepreneurs
um he's an entrepreneur you know podcast
and [__] to just say you got to do it
you're gonna pump people up and tell
them to do it like yeah man you ain't
got to do [__] in fact if you don't want
that if you if you don't want that I
kind of admire you you know like I I
like I'm saying I gotta I'm a little
jealous like that you don't have the
same Ambitions right because I feel like
my ambition has been a curse you know
what I'm saying like I could have
yeah yeah I built I made a whole lot of
money you know I'm saying a whole lot of
money but like it's like a [__] behind
me man it's a trail of [__] tears and
damage you know what I'm saying like
late night sweats
um [__] ruin relationships you know
failures you know it's like it's like a
and and those stories are everyone right
everyone has the stories you know and
even though I sell the court that's not
a course but I sell the coaching program
on how to become entrepreneur like if yo
if you don't want to do that [__]
I get it bro this [__] is not for
everybody man and there's a lot of
people who would be happy with just a
job they they enjoy man you know it's
like a lot of people will be happy with
a job they enjoy man you know yeah I
think I think that's a pretty good way
to look at it yeah and there's no shame
in that like these entrepreneur
[__]
will try to shame people into into it
you know if you got a job you're a dummy
you're stupid like yo shut up man such a
[__] ass up man so the [__] [__] up
you know I'd be wanting to fight these
[__] because it's just not it's
not the truth and it's not reality and
it's not even how the world works right
we need people to have jobs like we need
doctors we need paramedics we need
police officers you know what I'm saying
like these these are important parts of
our community you know what I'm saying
in the same into [__] shame this
person for working hard
yeah no you you make a really good point
um yeah there's a lot of uh hysteria
right now about being an entrepreneur
and you got to do this you're gonna be
up at this time and you gotta you gotta
do [__] man yeah right if you want to
though you gotta you should go for it
right the people who want to do it right
they'll self-select you know it's kind
of um
like I don't I don't try to guide people
down that path because I'm like because
I know how much pain it's gonna cause
them to go down that path you know like
like you want to make a million dollars
like that's gonna be yeah it's gonna be
painful and you're gonna it's gonna it's
gonna cost it's gonna cost you
everything and I think you know it's not
just like money and business it's just
like if you generally have higher
standards for yourself in life yeah then
yeah it's a pretty yeah it sucks it's
Bill Focus isn't it because you're just
there just like oh no only this works
and you you know you have to get that
otherwise you're not going to be happy I
don't try to persuade people to go down
there that that path right but if they
want to go down that path all right
let's go let's go I'll be like if you
want to climb Mount Everest you know I'm
the [__] Sherpa right but
it's like I'm not trying to say
everybody should climb out Mount Everest
you know you got to self-select for that
you know yeah and how and how do people
do that so like what kind of individual
would make a good entrepreneur like what
qualities do they need you know what man
I think you got to be good at uh
it's funny man like the qualities I
think will make a good entrepreneur
that person is probably less likely to
go down that path right
um because you got to be willing to
learn
you got it you can't have a like a bit
you you kind of can't have an ego an ego
in the sense of like you know everything
like you know what's right because you
gotta you gotta be super like willing to
learn and and take mentors be a mentor
be an apprentice you know what I'm
saying that the mentor Apprentice
relationship is like the only
relationship that never fails you know
what I'm saying like I mean that's the
only form of learning that never fails
the mentor mentee relationship right you
know you can you can read a book about
swimming but that ain't gonna make you
Michael Phelps right and you can read a
book about Navy Seals man but that don't
mean you ready to go to Iraq you know
what I'm saying like you've got you if
you want to be a Navy SEAL you got to
get you gotta what you got to be a
mentee you got to go to Buds and you
gotta train with the [__] people who
already did it and they got to show you
the path and you got to be humble enough
to walk that path right and it's the
same [__] with uh entrepreneurship like
you're gonna have to get mentors maybe
you won't have to pay them maybe you
won't have to work for somebody you know
like for example one of my uh you know
my boy Harry simones he's from uh he's
from London he was an intern I and he
wanted to start this company
um for athletes like nice shirts and
clothes for athletes and uh I was like
you know what I'm saying I I help you
out he wanted to work with us so he he
worked he started working for me for
like years and um you know he learned a
lot and I was helping him with his ads
and he went in on this thing man and he
built this company called um tailored
athlete right and they they make like uh
you know
last I checked he was doing it oh in
eight in 2018 2019 he was doing like two
meal a year you know what I'm saying and
he's like under 25 you know but that so
I don't even know how much he's doing
now like I gotta I gotta check in him
he's coming to Miami so but it's like
that Mentor mentee relationship helped
him expedite that process right but
that's not always like the guy who's
gonna gonna do it right the guy who's
gonna jump into it has got a guy's
[__]
you know he done he's full of [__]
Red Bull and cocaine or some [__] he's
like all hypey he just want to do and he
thinks he's the man especially here in
Miami you know
and uh
you know that this guy's he's gonna have
a harder time I think you know
I guess because like it's sort of coming
from the wrong place it's coming from a
place of like I want to be the man like
I want to show what I'm doing as opposed
to like this is something that I love
and this is this is like my baby and
it's something that I want to grow and
and turn into some I don't know yeah I
mean maybe right you know what I think
you're right about the first part
because I because to build a big
business right is is super rare to meet
a one-person Million Dollar business you
know what I'm saying so at some point
you're going to have to like start
hiring people and be a leader right but
that the kind of guy that you described
like he thinks it's all about him right
so right I look at leadership
I look at leadership like the people who
I lead like I work for them right they
they took the risk to join my to join
you know the path I'm going on right
they could be doing something else and
my job is to make sure they're taken
care of so like I remember especially in
the earlier days it was sometimes man I
had to pay everybody
and you know I don't get paid yeah like
and it's like you know but it that's
that's the price of leadership you know
you gotta leave from the front kind of
like when the birds fly in that v
formation yeah or they do that because
the burden front is working the hardest
right but
because of the aerodynamics it makes it
easier for the other birds to fly and
that's how they can go like long
distances but the burden in the front
he's the leader right he's working the
hardest you know what I'm saying he's
working he's working for the team right
and that's that's how I look at it man
like I
you know sometimes I want to chill or
take a day off or do whatever like nah
man this [__] teams depending on me
man like you know saying I can't I can't
never let them down I get you know I'm
gonna make sure I make payroll I'm gonna
make sure I help them accomplish their
goals you know they got kids they got
they got families you know they need to
make sure they eat you know and even and
even the students right like my my
clients we I lead them to are like I
gotta make sure that they good you know
whatever I got going on in my life you
know whatever troubles are uh uh trauma
I'm going through I gotta like put that
aside for the for the for the team right
because that's what a Leader's supposed
to do right so the guy who's like thinks
it's all about him he ain't gonna do
that he gonna fail you know what I'm
saying yeah no I really respect that
mindset um I think it's uh it's a
mindset which is lacking in society now
um you know it's very stoic it's very uh
it's very disciplined
um and something that I have noticed and
I'm curious if you've noticed this or
felt any of this you know if a man is is
saying you know I want to be a leader
um it naturally comes with aggression
and a level of competitive
and all of that I feel like these sort
of character traits are um these sort of
traits are called like toxically
masculine and and a sort of shamed and
you know young men are told not to be
like that yeah so have you noticed
anything like this have you have you had
any like backlash food you know being
the way that you are just curious I get
a lot of backlash anyway you know you
you know you can't please everybody
nobody gets unanimous praise right they
they killed Jesus you know for what I
hear he seemed like a pretty cool guy
it seems like he has some good ideas you
know uh but you know I don't know
as far as what you're talking about
though I never got backlash for that
right because I'm talking about I'm
talking about leadership from the point
of like
understand like I work for them right I
work I work for the people I lead my job
is to make sure that they that they are
good you know what I'm saying and then
as a result
the whole team wins you know I'm saying
yeah I gotta go I gotta go the hardest
so I think the guys who get that
backlash they they get on the podcast or
[__] whatever and say I gotta lead
I'm gonna be leader and they try to
force that [__] upon people right that
it's you know if he was really the man
people would be excited to follow you
you know you wouldn't have to say
nothing you know what I'm saying like
yeah like I'm not out here like
struggling to get people to work for me
man I'll turn it down I have like
applications you know what I'm saying
like I'm not I'm not uh yeah yeah we're
not like running ads to get you know we
got [__] tons of applications every
day you know for people who want to work
and feel different positions because
once you're popping once you've got it
popping right people people want to
attach themselves to you right so the
guy who's like yelling about being he
needs to be the leader is just like oh
that's a pure reflection that he doesn't
have enough pop he doesn't have a pop in
in a way where people are excited to be
led by him you know what I'm saying like
if he was really if he was really
getting it popping then they would want
to do it you know everybody would know
about it yeah yeah so like you gotta be
so he he probably should do some more
self-reflection yeah that makes sense
yeah
um I've been reading some statistics
which say that men's testosterone has
plummeted so apparently what is regarded
as
um as high or normal now according to
doctors and experts would be seen as low
back in like the 60s or 70s can you do
you have any insight on that do you know
why that might be uh men's testosterone
levels
nah
you know
and then try and get that
that's up they're taking
or did they take like Trend or something
yeah and stuff like that anabolics and
about serious that's different they're
not trying to get they're not trying to
get like reach uh they're not trying to
get their [__] like to a normal rate
they're trying to be like you know
superhuman yeah
on something like that yeah I think
that's good or bad listen what I don't
give a [__] about what nobody does with
their own body man that's none of my
business you know you know like like
people from like a trainer's perspective
like of course like if people are trying
to reach certain levels you know they
want to look like you but maybe perhaps
they they naturally have a much smaller
build like you'll build naturally quite
big
super scary yeah
that's all good
um
I started doing I started taking uh
testosterone replacement 30 I'm sorry
testosterone replacement therapy when I
was yeah when I was 38 right because I
just noticed it I was you know just a
little little bit of a lack of energy I
wasn't didn't have as much vigorous as I
once had and I went to the
I went to the the doctors you know it
was running on I can test on me and they
were doing blood work the only thing
that came back was that my testosterone
was kind of low so that's the thing I'm
surprised that they'd say it's low
because nowadays maybe it's your hair
and Miami's different I don't know I was
in New York yeah but um no it was it was
low for even what the standard is now
you know and
so they just they just get now I'll take
the testosterone replacement therapy you
know I'm saying I've been doing that for
two years it's been fantastic uh but I
was in great shape before that you know
uh and the key is man if you want to if
you want to do what I did you just got
to do what I did so for example
I'm an extremist this is what you know
me I'm like a [__] crazy person okay
you see pretty chill right now I'm chill
I'm chill but like in real life but when
as it pertains to my goals or the
acquisition of like capital or anything
I'm trying to accomplish man like I'm
dead serious you know and uh but I keep
I've been keeping the scale on me at all
times a food scale on me for like 10
years yeah so you asked me like anything
any day pick any day 10 years I can tell
you exactly what I ate whatever how many
macros how much proteins you track
everything every single day everything
every every single day yeah and and how
much I burn right because it's all
calories and calories life is just math
this is what I'm trying to say people I
wish people understood this like it's so
life is so much simpler than people
think but they want to make it more
complex it's just math so as it pertains
to losing weight or building muscle it's
just it's math right you want to you
want to lose you want to lose fat
for cool man burn 500 calories a day
right put I mean put yourself in a 500
calorie deficit so check how many years
you're burning each day right eat 500
calories less than that each day right
you'll be you'll you'll burn 3 500
calories
uh that week if you do that you know
seven days a week and that's um 3 500
calories is one pound of fat right so
you do that for 10 weeks you lose 10
pounds in fact super super simple you
know it's like but it's all that like
it's that that's life in general like
there's not nothing is complex about
this [__] we just make it complex
because we care we we all
give a [__] about [__] that we don't
really need to give a [__] about you
know saying like what we I don't know
man people are just always so upset and
emotional about [__] that's like not
really important if they just really
focused on the parameters they needed to
focus on to accomplish their goals and
kind of just ignore the rest right I
don't give a [__] with nobody else is
doing with their body man I don't give a
[__] like I you know I see people like
getting mad over like certain [__] they
see ah they doing this they're doing
that they don't give a [__] what they
doing you know what I'm saying
Yeah you sort of um you remind me that's
like this meme I I doubt people have
seen it it's just something which I
thought was always funny and you remind
me of that it's kind of like at the end
of like a long meeting when everybody
has all these different opinions if you
just chime in at the end and you say
it's all about finding a balance
everyone's gonna go yeah that's what you
just remind me of you're just like it's
all about fighting a balance yeah no
life is way simpler than than people
um
okay just back to the food for a sec is
there anything which is like bad though
like I'm curious what do you think about
like protein powders what do you think
about like protein bars are these bad or
yeah what like as far as what reasons
I don't know apparently there's like
stuff inside it which is bad for you
like bad for your gut bad for your
digestion
because this is like
I mean if you if you had like the
question is just too vague oh okay
and bad for who
okay so let's take me as an example
right I eat five times a day Okay cool
so have like breakfast snack lunch snack
dinner all right and I don't mean like
like unhealthy snack it'll obviously be
like a small meal or something
um and I have I have oh I had a
nutritionist that recommended protein
bars okay um and I really like them um
because I just feel like they just fill
me up yeah and it's perfect and like
gives me the energy and I'm good to go
and it's like quick and it's fast but
people around me including my brother
and some other uh people that we filmed
with the production people we filmed
with say Don't eat those what I don't
know good why is it bad why don't you
come on and tell us he's been in my ears
I'm not saying he's right or wrong I'm
just kind of out of curiosity let's see
what he thinks yeah I mean all I'm
saying is I think the body
um wants to have something really
natural and uh protein bars other
supplements protein powders
um it's very hard for your body to break
them down and maybe your acidic levels
have to go higher or protein powder it's
hard in comparison to what in comparison
to having let's say
um a steak grilled chicken breast so
protein powder is more difficult to
digest that yes because it's highly
highly processed and your stomach isn't
it's our bodies haven't evolved to eat
um processed food
um it's the same thing if you had like a
processed bug or the same thing as
opposed to having like a really raw
burger or raw steak or raw River what
are the ramifications of that uh gut
inflammation stomachache
um constipation is that is that is those
problems you have you constipated I love
it oh great so like for example I've had
ice have like a lot of protein bars as
well and I would find that they would
like
um yeah they would just give me bad
stomach ache unless my stomach was
completely empty it was ready to just
like take it all down but let's say I
had it with something else it's like
it's too much food yeah you haven't had
that experience
protein stuff
and they get your experience right but
like you know there's some there's some
[__] for example if I if I was to eat
like a
something real sugary right now I would
be so super tired after you know what
I'm saying because my body's not
accustomed to that right but like you
can eat the same thing and you might be
fine right so like I don't know I think
listen I'm not trying to negate anything
you guys are saying right I'm just
saying like I think we're a lot humans
are super eager to to impose
our viewpoints and our ideologies on
other humans like you're so glad you're
humans are like no I mean it's a natural
thing you know that I mean
that's how religion gets spread you know
I'm saying like [__] have War
just to [__] spread a religion it's
like why you give a [__] without why you
give a [__] what I believe you know I'm
saying like it's weird you know people
get mad if you say that this ain't gonna
work or this will work and it's you know
because we're tribal people right so
like it's in our DNA we're descendants
of people who like grew up in tribes and
the more the more the more aligned you
were with the tribe the greater your
your your
um you know this like prehistoric times
right it's a long long time the the more
you align with the tribe the greater
your
um
more likely you are to survive right and
those people they did survive right and
they passed their genes on to the rest
of us and their DNA and and so it's it's
in us to want to like group these camps
you know whether it be you see it in in
the food in the fitness industry
crossfitters man I think that's the best
powerless I think that's the best
bodybuilders things that's the best
vegans think that [__] is the best keto
guys think their [__] is the best you
see it you see all all type of [__]
cities you know what I'm saying like
sports you know like whatever you like
you we want to [__] almost like we
want to evangelize everything we believe
in but I don't know for me personally I
just always try to like mitigate my
natural inclination to impose my
viewpoints upon others you know in a way
where it's like you know man if you find
something that works for you man then
like I'm excited for you I want you to
keep doing it you know yeah I I um I
completely agree with that no I think uh
the tribalism like we're in crypto a lot
as well and there's lots of tribalism
they're like oh bitcoin's the best
ethereum's the best so I agree with with
you on that for sure and and your
analysis on the whole like why we do it
is spot on you're so right like it's
prehistoric times you want to fit in
with the group and stuff like that and
and Leia was looking at me when you said
imposing your will because I told her a
lot of things and maybe it gets too much
I don't know but like just back okay
just back to the food thing but it means
world right right like he is he's not
trying to be he's not trying to be at
like nobody's I don't think most people
aren't trying to be [__] right yeah
they just you know you you get like a a
serotonin Rush when you are in part of a
tribe like it builds a and it makes you
want to defend that tribe and like get
it get excited about it right you know
it's it's weird man if I go to if I go
to another city you know I live in Miami
now but if I meet somebody from Chicago
like we're all excited man I don't like
everyone in Chicago like [__]
in Chicago robbed me and [__] you know
like I had to [__] up a lot of people in
Chicago man I had to send my [__]
Chicago to the emergency room right but
it's like soon as we're outside it's
like oh we're now with tribes now now
it's us you know it's it's normal [__]
you know and and I most of the time most
of the time people mean well especially
like in your sibling relationship yeah
like obviously I'm always it comes from
a place where I'm looking out for Leia
for sure 100 but just back to the food
thing I was just gonna say my this is my
personal experience and I know it's also
helped a lot of people so I've
completely cut out all carbohydrates
yeah yeah except for yeah yeah of course
even when I just said I got excited when
I heard you say that yeah
that's a natural thing it's mainly
starch starch carbohydrate so I don't
eat potatoes pasta flour uh uh uh what
else um rice
um I will only get my carbs from like
avocado blueberries maybe an apple or
banana because banana is so high in
sugar I also try I've cut out sugar as
well
um I just don't want to spike my blood
sugar levels um and that's worked for me
because I found carbs again because a
lot of it was process refined and it's
not natural like we only started with
carbs like 10 000 years ago with crops
and all this kind of stuff in China like
it my body or I think everyone's hasn't
evolved to digest this stuff and I love
having an all uh animal based diet not
Carnival I would say but animal base so
like if it walks swims or flies I eat it
yeah
yeah no I mean that's working for me a
lot but even like him saying that like I
got like even I got like oh man he's one
of us right it's like it's a natural
inclination you know what I'm saying I
think it's normal I'm curious to know
can you tell us your diet I'd love to
hear like can you walk us through like
what you're eating and also like your
training how often you're training and
what time you get up go to sleep I'm
very curious to hear this yeah if that's
okay yeah no problem
um
for me man it's like first of all I just
want to say man like
I don't want nobody to attempt to try to
do what I'm about to say okay I feel
like this is like you know WWE try this
at home don't do this [__] man like one
is you know you won't [__] saying
it's tough as me right you know and I'm
I say that with love you know you're
gonna hurt yourself
you're gonna [__] hurt yourself or
and or you're not gonna be able to do it
it's gonna [__] with your self-esteem
you know
and I want you to have like a long love
loving happy life you know with the
people with the people you you with the
people you care about all right so for
me it's like I eat I get close to like
zero carbs every day like zero net carbs
at least right so I might get some cars
but you know when net carbs are
different why do you get those problems
you know they'll be like Trace Amounts
and [__] you know like it'll be like you
know cheese might have like one or two
cars in there you know not not even milk
right you know if I I'm a big fan of
protein shakes away protein shakes so I
drink a lot of those throughout the day
in order to get my protein levels up
real high
um and you know the way way protein is
made it's like it's made it's just whey
protein come it's a it's a byproduct of
the cheese manufacturing process right
so it's like and uh this isn't baby food
and [__] you know like I don't know I
figure like I'm tougher than a baby
right in a baby
baby it's in baby formula it don't be
killing babies I I think I'd be out you
know so but that's just me right you
know I want everybody to do what's best
for them man you know I want everybody
to be happy man
stay stay positive and optimistic but
for me there's a lot of protein shakes
you know a lot of uh a lot of meat eggs
um
a lot of meat and eggs man you know what
I'm saying and a lot of cheese this this
morning I had just a [__] ton of
cheese eggs and I waited like what does
that mean like how many eggs did you
have yeah yeah no no so um I ordered it
right so I had to I had to weigh it
you know when you would the when you get
like eggs just made like that they don't
necessarily tell you how many eggs and I
don't even trust them [__]
sometimes right so I just waited it was
like 10 ounces of eggs okay
and then I had uh I had two protein
shakes and that's all I had today so far
right but it's early you know it's like
two quarter to three and
I'll probably have some more you know
what so here's what I eat a big
breakfast right and I eat a big dinner
and I have like shakes in between a day
right I like that yeah yeah yeah I I
really like that because Eden slows me
down not necessarily like with my diet I
don't get like crazy glucose spikes so
it I don't get tired after I work that's
my main thing about keto right it keeps
my blood levels like super stable I wore
a continuous glucose monitor for like a
month just to see what would interact
and almost every day I thought I was
fasting because my my glucose levels
were so we're so like flat you know and
uh but some there was a few things that
spiked in and it was cool that was cool
data to like take those things out of my
uh my diet you know and um anyway
excuse me
yo funny fact McDonald's so I will I
will say about the meat [__] y'all
talking about
I I remember I was wearing that blood
glucose and I wore I ate a McDonald's
cheeseburger with no bun right no but
just the cheese just a bird just a Patty
and cheese right [__] glucose levels
fighting there you go there's something
else in there they're putting something
else in they're putting something else
in there right but if I just get like
some straight up brisket not even
organic she just brisket from the
barbecue spot stay flat so it's like
it's interesting you know there's
something there's something going on in
there anyway
um
you the reason I don't get tired I'm
gonna go I'm gonna answer your question
I promise you I'm going kid it's okay
the reason I don't get I don't get tired
after I eat like a lot of people they'll
eat a big meal and they're tired you
know they get like afternoon slumps or
Pros you know that don't happen to me
because I'm going because of Keto right
so and the reason what makes you tired
yes it's so when you when you're eating
carbohydrates right
um that can that gets um converted into
glucose right and when your glucose
levels go above 110 your blood glucose
levels go above 110 your pancreas will
secrete a hormone called insulin right
and insulin's jobs to like get rid of
that excess blood sugar right but
they'll take that [__] from everywhere
and they'll take it like from your brain
and and it's kind of indiscriminate
about the way it takes it up right so
you might get a [__] dipping blood
sugar after that because it's taking so
much out and that's where the tiredness
comes from it's the it's insulin's way
of like protecting you and [__] right
like and it's a good thing that your
body does that if it didn't have that
you die right the people with type 1
diabetes they have to inject insulin
because their bodies don't produce it
you know
um fun fact most people with type 1
diabetes are super skinny like if you
notice like taking inventory people you
know who's like born with type one
they're probably like skinny right
because they don't make insulin and
think about it I don't know just think
about it right it's because insulin is
an antibiotic hormone but it's
indiscriminately anabolic right so it'll
help um it help grow muscle cells and
fat cells right I'm saying like it's
indiscriminately anabolic uh so most
people who were born with type 1 by
diabetes they don't produce insulin so
they're like a super [__] um skinny
naturally most of the time with type 2
diabetes those fat boys who got like too
fat and then you know and they lost
insulin sensitivity they had so much
insulin that they don't have sensitivity
to it anymore so they have to inject it
right but the type 1 diabetes they were
just born with it they're just pancreas
didn't make insulin
um so they're super skinny however
they'll die right if they eat the wrong
thing right so hey Life's a game of
trade-offs anyway they uh they uh so
anyway
I'll still get like slow if I eat a big
if I sometimes not not tired that same
way but I think it's just actual eating
sorry eating is time consuming you got
to stop working so I'd like the way I
wake up and like I'll answer all the I I
wake up usually around 4 35. wow but
I'll sleep if my body needs more sleep
like I can tell when I wake up is
listen that's why [__] can't do
what I do right because they'll just
think oh I'm tired and go back to sleep
but
I've been doing this [__] for so long I
know I probably need more sleeping and
I'll take more if I need to right what
time are you going to bed you know I'm
trying to get to bed at 9 30 10. yeah
yeah you know it's just
you know that's that's probably the
hardest part do you drink any alcohol no
no drink no alcohol no alcohol no
recreational drugs yeah yeah no alcohol
no recreational drugs none of that [__]
you know um I I don't have no like bias
against it you know I I don't want I
don't I don't care what anybody does in
fact if you like somebody who's
competing with me I I suggest man you
should go man doesn't live life enjoy
life man get as drunk as possible
[__] do all that [__] yeah you gotta
you gotta enjoy life bro you know
but for me man I want to stay on point
you know and um yeah I wake up like four
and I probably won't I I probably the
first thing I do is I I drink like this
saltwater Contraption like salt water in
this [__] called um
called Ketone Aid it's like exogenous
ketones it should tastes like gorilla
piss right I'd imagine I imagine I don't
have a lot of experience with it
and and
yo you you take that [__] on an empty
stomach man it's like even if you're not
on keto you take a show easy stomach you
don't feel like some kind of energy if
you can if you can [__]
deal with drinking is [__] gross
right I do that in like some salt water
and then I just start working like
immediately you know what I'm saying I
work I work until like the sun's about
to rise and then that's what I take the
first break I'll probably I'll probably
have uh three four shots of espresso
we'll mix with the protein shake
I'm going hard out here you know and uh
and then I then then it's like you know
cold shower shave all this [__] and then
not to go for then I usually go walk as
the sun's Rising I go for a walk on the
[__] ocean I got something else to go
for a walk then I come then uh then I
that's probably the first gym session is
coming back from there right and you
know mostly most people most people work
out for like an hour a day right that's
normal right this makes sense right
um I do the same but I break it up into
three
20 minute sessions I don't have no data
to support this right so like yeah
whatever you know what I'm saying but I
my my theory is
you know when you work out
for an hour in the morning I used to do
that and I would be a little
drained you know what I'm saying
especially if you do squats or deadlifts
or some some of this like because those
big compound movements are hard on in
certain nervous system you know that's
why you get tired after and
but if I if I do a 20 minute session
right then I can just get back to work I
still got a lot in the tank right then
rest for a few I'll do some other [__]
for a few hours then do another 20
minute session then yeah and then
another one at the end it's the same
amount of time but it's like I wasn't
like dead after the workouts especially
because I go [__] hard when I work
out right like if it's
people who say they love working out man
not lying well they they might it might
be true they just you know they're not
working out the way I work out they
wouldn't love it if I trained them you
know what I'm saying I made NFL players
throw up you know like like if you work
out like I work out you probably hate it
you know what I'm saying like I I don't
really like it I don't really enjoy it I
never liked it you know it's just a
means to it and uh
um but some people like it and that's
cool now I'm not trying to say this [__]
uh but I just do the 20 minutes boom
back to work
it breaks up the day a little bit and
I'm not like super tired after it you
know that's very helpful and I also have
another theory about it you know like if
you say a boxer right 12 round fight
he's gonna have more energy the first
few rounds than he will the last few
rounds right it's [__] normal right
because as as you increase duration
intensity will naturally decrease right
so what if you just had those Beginnings
right three of those Beginnings right
then it stands to reason that that it's
the same amount of time but because
they're spread out
you can do each one of those like with
that same beginning intensity right so
the the total amount of minutes will be
a more intense amount of minutes it's
just a theory though I haven't like did
no studies or I'm sure yeah no I think I
think it's really interesting I think it
just depends on you know what kind of
person you are you know what kind of
character you are for me I could just
never ever do that just for like
multiple reasons like like one moment I
went like I don't like to work out in a
full stomach and maybe like what am I
eating what am I working out that's okay
right so my first meals after that first
work exactly and most of the time it's
most of the time that very first meal is
actually sardines like two cans of
sardines because I just eat them real
quick I don't do no dishes I don't
[__] cook no food yeah I don't clean
nothing [__] that [__]
yeah I mean I I could do it if I try to
spend all my time
all my time either doing Something's
Gonna Make me money or spending time
with my friends and family yeah and
that's it like nothing like
I don't try to spend no time doing
nothing else so that includes [__]
cleaning clue if I love if I enjoyed
cleaning then that's cool right but you
know I don't really identify as a
[__] maid
but you know if I like that [__] if I
was on some Martha Stewart [__] then you
know that that's then I would do it you
know but I it's not my thing so okay no
that makes sense yeah yeah I think um I
think it was Andrew Tate who went viral
with the whole idea of like you know
you're broke what are you doing sitting
there that was on your show right uh no
it was on a different show okay maybe
maybe I think I asked him about it on my
show anyway but he was like you're broke
why are you sitting there chopping
onions like what are you doing yeah me
and him [__] CI on that on that issue
man Andrew's my guy like I know Andrew
since like 2018 yeah like before like he
really blew up yeah we we I kicked it
with him and Tristan a few times man
those the homies you know yeah but yeah
[__] all that [__] all that cooking
clean and [__] man just make money just
make money go see your family and I just
want to spend time with my as much time
as possible Mark with the people I love
that's good and I want to [__] make
spend time making money that's all I
really all I want to do right you know
somebody else may have different
priorities you know they might want to
spend their free time in other other
methods you know that's just that's just
it that's not the type of [__] I'm on so
I just had the maid come and that's cool
too right because now you know it gets
[__] single mother man you pay her
man we spread the money throughout the
economy man it's beautiful
you don't drive on purpose you know like
well I I got rid of my car when I moved
to New York and I lived in Manhattan for
like 15 years and having a car was kind
of a pain in the ass and Uber was just
convenient there and now I live in Miami
I was like nah [__] that [__] I ain't
driving you know because I can walk in
the Uber you're working the Uber exactly
people like people try to clown me for
that [__] no that's because they [__]
[__] there's a whole like there's a
whole movie about The Lincoln Lawyer the
guy the the guy well it's obviously not
real but he he doesn't drive so he can
like work and like do cases yeah yeah
I'm on my Lincoln Lawyer [__] exactly
you know like I made legit money
yeah but I watched the series it's not
with Matthew McConaughey but it's the
same thing he drives in the car I think
like real money doing this you know you
gotta really
you know for for me man
like I see a lot of people like getting
mad on social media about [__]
everything all the time right yeah and
uh my life just I really just simplify
my life man it's like not about my
friends family or making money then like
I don't give up that's perfect I'm
saying so I concentrate everything on
that like I care about those things like
a lot and I don't care about nothing I'm
not say I don't care I got compassion
for people who are struggling all that
[__] but it's like yo I can't save the
world I can't change the whole world but
I can change my world I agree with you
that's my mind's not I'm like I I don't
care about what's going on right that
like I need to deal with me and my
family and that's all that matters and
maybe once I've saved the home then
maybe we can talk about something else
but you got your [__] together what you
got your [__] together you got it really
really you got it popping you know like
I mean I got I got I got some money man
right but it's like you know like I
can't I can't save the whales or the
Dolphins now so I ain't even gonna trip
about it you know but you know if I get
to like some huge numbers and maybe you
know I can devote some time to like you
know the dog saving the dolphins whales
marine life [__] kids in Africa and
then I'll worry about that [__] man but
you go you know it's like that's just
everything is a distraction right now
where can people follow you um get in
touch with you you know if they want to
hire you or anything like that how do
people follow you and get in touch with
you listen man I I I'm all social media
my my Instagram is King keto
um
you know it's the one with a million
father uh Tick Tock my Tick Tock is Big
Brandon Carter some [__] nerd took
kinky though it's cool they ain't doing
nothing with him man and uh yeah but you
know uh my Instagram yes big Brandon
Carter I mean my I'm sorry my Tick Tock
is Big Brandon Carter but it's the same
[__] I post on YouTube shorts same same
exact [__] content man so like
YouTube's a good place of comedy and if
you wanna if you wanna uh work if you
want to like hire work with the team if
you want you know that join the
mentorship program man you probably
don't man you're probably too soft I'm
gonna be honest with you man
you're probably not tough enough for
this [__] man so you should probably
just keep doing what you're doing man
try to like make peace with like what
you are I'm sure you have redeeming
qualities outside of your work ethic you
know and you should just focus on those
man be happy man learn to enjoy life
don't try too hard yeah man maybe you
should just enjoy life man yeah
well Brandon I want to thank you so much
um I really appreciate you coming on the
show I find it really valuable I hope
you know everyone watching I'm sure they
find it really valuable as well and like
I said Gideon and I we're just like
trying to get the diet right right now
you know we're just like fighting
arguing over like what's the best way to
do it so I really appreciate it
start with the calories and then once
you got that [__] in order calories and
protein calories then protein everything
else okay well I really appreciate you
coming on it's been really valuable so
thank you thank you man I appreciate it
awesome guys thank you so much for
watching if you enjoyed this video then
don't forget to hit the like button and
subscribe as we have more of this
content coming